les autorités prennent les grands moyens
en haine pour empêcher la propagation de
la coved 19
les policiers ne se gêne pas pour
frapper ceux qui ne respectent pas
l'ordre d'isolement la population
entière 1,3 milliard de personnes est en
confinement pendant trois semaines il
faut sauver le pays a dit le premier
ministre indien narendra modi notre
situation est vraiment difficile d'y
vivre des médias canadiens coincés à
mumbai
il tente de revenir au pays depuis des
semaines est rare que quatre des six
chaînes chose c'est presque est possible
d'acheter les choses essentielles tout
est fermé
impossible également de se déplacer il
n'y a même plus de vols domestiques dit
il il est loin d'être le seul près de
15000 canadien se trouverait en inde des
moments d'angoissé pour un couple dont
le fils est seul dans la région de
délits
j'ai essayé de le sortir des vingt neuf
lors deux semaines et déjà d'or rejoint
de la compagnie avec qui a fait sur
booking sont prévus d'avions
je suis allé dans ma chambre puis j'ai
accès à de l'eau de la nourriture
c'est dans cette chambre que remy dit on
devra passer les trois prochaines
semaines
mais il ya déjà un site qui permet de
rester trois semaines quatre semaines
cinq semaines dans un pays étranger ils
ont soit des médicaments de prescription
à obtenir et aussi fait le logement est
très difficile à obtenir
par contre je crois que ça va aller en
s'empirant et puis ça pourrait devenir
dangereux
carole vadeboncoeur habite avec une
famille indienne elle se sent en
sécurité
mais la tension est bien présente j'ai
remarqué les jackets qui croyaient ils
mettaient souvent un masque devant leurs
visages tout lui va très bien
la situation est critique nous avons
besoin des de notre gouvernement
implore vivek deredia ottawa dit
collaborer avec le gouvernement indien
ici marie michel lauzon radio-canada à
montréal